Je vais relire les premiers paragraphes de la confession de foi sur ces chapitres sur la chute, les péchés et les châtiments.
Et pendant que notre sœur faisait la lecture des romans 5, je me suis rappelé du début de ma foi,
où j'étais en train de lire toute la Bible, et j'ai croisé ces textes,
qui pour moi à l'époque étaient vraiment très difficiles, même si j'avais une compréhension suffisante,
mais c'était certainement l'un de ces passages que pour un nouveau-né chrétien, les langages judiciaires étaient en défi.
Mais heureusement, par la grâce des dieux, j'ai pu comprendre que c'était un défi non seulement pour les nouveaux dans la foi, plus tard,
car même aujourd'hui, je peux reconnaître en fait quelques difficultés,
car ça parle des transactions qui sont quelque part au-delà de notre juridiction,
qui nous élèvent à la compréhension des dieux.
Et à chaque fois qu'on croise des versets comme ça dans la Bible, il faut nous rappeler des deux choses.
La Bible a été écrite pour des personnes très simples, des personnes très simples dans la société,
des personnes qui étaient persécutées.
La plupart des lecteurs bibliques, l'apôtre Paul l'a dit lui-même,
en écrivant Corinthian, il dit « Dieu ne nous a pas choisis beaucoup d'entre nous comme les plus cultivés dans la société ».
Mais c'est très important de nous rappeler,
si Dieu a décidé de préserver certains textes,
il nous pousse plus à la compréhension et à la réflexion,
c'est car lui a la capacité de se communiquer avec efficacité,
et il voit en nous du potentiel pour être élevé à ses compréhensions.
Et donc, les plus importants pour saisir les saluts sont vraiment très clairs et très simples dans la Bible,
mais même les passages qui sont un peu plus difficiles,
c'est de l'intention des dieux pour nous élever,
car il sait que nous avons la capacité d'agrandir notre compréhension,
d'élargir notre intellect.
Et ça me fait toujours penser à Lloyd-Jones,
il disait en fait qu'il y a des personnes,
et c'est ça en fait un des secrets,
pour l'obstacle des compréhensions pour certains dans la communauté.
Les plus grands obstacles ne sont pas des obstacles de clarté biblique,
ni la capacité qu'on aurait pu avoir de saisir les vérités bibliques.
Ce sont les obstacles d'un verre qui est déjà très rempli.
Et quand on est des verres très remplis,
il n'y a plus de choses qui puissent rentrer.
Voilà pourquoi Jérémie dit, il faut d'abord détruire pour rebâtir,
et arracher pour planter.
Ce sont des préconceptions parfois qui nous empêchent d'accueillir la vérité telle qu'elle est.
Et ce sont des crises de notre propre orgueil et arrogance parfois,
qui nous empêchent d'embrasser la vérité.
Alors Lloyd-Jones disait,
certaines personnes critiquent la manière apparemment très sophistiquée,
la manière dont je parle,
ou des conceptions très profondes que j'essaie d'apporter.
Mais quand j'étais malade, lui, quand il était malade,
il a reçu une lettre d'une fille de 10 ans,
qui lui disait,
« Réviens aux poupitres, Lloyd-Jones.
Tu es le seul prédicateur que j'arrive à comprendre. »
Une fille de 10 ans.
Donc c'est très important pour nous,
de savoir chérir en fait.
Si Dieu a décidé d'enregistrer des passages qui sont un peu plus compliqués,
c'est car il sait que nous avons la capacité de nous exercer
et d'augmenter notre compréhension.
Donc, bien que Dieu ait créé l'homme droit et parfait,
et lui ait donné une loi juste,
qui était en vue de la vie,
s'il avait observé et qu'il ait menacé des morts,
s'il transgressait,
l'homme n'a pas gardé longtemps cet honneur.
Utilisant subtilement les serpents,
Satan séduisit Ève,
et par elle, il séduisit Adam,
qui s'encontrante sur lui,
transgressa volontairement la loi de leur création
et les commandements qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit défendu.
Donc jusqu'ici,
un écho de ce qu'on a pu méditer
dans toutes les expositions bibliques,
la grande première partie qu'on a faite,
la base d'autorité suprême,
c'est la Bible elle-même,
c'est en respirant l'atmosphère biblique,
et qu'on va être équipé pour comprendre
ce qu'on va organiser dans un système par la doctrine.
Et avant donc de passer aux explications plus doctrinales,
les rédacteurs de la confession des foies,
ils ont trouvé bon
de faire presque une répétition
de l'enregistrement biblique
qui décrit la chute
telle qu'elle s'est passée
de manière historique
et telle qu'elle a été enregistrée
historiquement dans la parole des dieux.
Donc là, à nouveau,
on a considéré
l'impossibilité même
d'une interprétation
qui ne soit pas historique et littérale
selon les interprétations
intra-bibliques elles-mêmes.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Les serpents littérales.
Un Satan véritable
en utilisant un serpent littéral.
Nous pouvons,
de manière extra-biblique,
chercher à forcer les textes
et traiter les textes bibliques
d'une manière complètement différente
de ce que la Bible elle-même
a toujours traité.
Et l'intentionnalité
des rédacteurs de la confession des foies,
c'était de répéter
de manière très littérale
l'interprétation
de cet enregistrement historique.
Donc l'objectif primaire,
c'est
voici l'histoire
telle qu'elle nous est présentée
de manière inhérente
dans la Bible.
Voilà la chute de l'homme.
Et à partir de là,
un apport doctrinal aussi
par cette dernière phrase,
il n'a plus à Dieu
de permettre cette chute
dans son conseil sage et sang,
puisqu'il avait déterminé
de l'utiliser
pour manifester sa gloire.
Donc là,
on voit par ces récits
la même préoccupation
du récit biblique
de démontrer clairement
que l'homme,
elle est seule
et totalement responsable
pour la chute
de l'humanité.
Par contre,
Dieu n'a pas perdu
sa souveraineté.
Rien n'a surpris
les plans A des dieux.
Même si Dieu n'était pas impliqué
dans les péchés,
dans la chute,
Dieu,
il a permis
que ces êtres responsables
échouent
afin de gouverner l'histoire
de manière à manifester
sa gloire
par la rédemption.
Donc responsabilité humaine
encadrée
par la souveraineté des dieux,
Dieu reste Dieu
et l'homme
est responsable
pour la chute.
Donc voilà comment
on harmonise
par les premiers paragraphes
de la confession de foi
tout ce qu'on a appris
jusqu'ici
à propos
des décrets éternels
des dieux,
du caractère saint
et immuable des dieux,
du fait que Dieu
a toute la puissance,
qu'il est omniscient,
qu'il n'y a rien
qui ne peut prendre Dieu
par surprise
et aucune chose
ne peut frustrer ses plans.
Dieu est Dieu.
La chute n'a pas enlevé
la divinité des dieux.
OK ?
Et donc on passe
aux descriptions
plus doctrinales
ou doctrinaires.
Quelle est la correcte ?
Doctrinale ?
OK ?
Cour des théologies
et cours des français
en même temps.
Bon.
L'exposition doctrinale
plus directe,
le paragraphe 2,
on a parlé du péché
pour parler aussi
de la doctrine principale
qui est la doctrine
du péché originel.
OK ?
Et donc,
pour comprendre
les péchés originels,
il faut comprendre d'abord
ce qu'est les péchés.
Donc on a traité
cette question
en considérant
ce qu'est les péchés.
Et donc les péchés
sont quelque chose
qui n'est pas tout simplement
la privation d'un bien,
il n'est pas quelque chose
de quantitatif tout simplement.
Dieu est absolument pur,
la sainteté est un concept
qualificateur
et pas quantitatif.
Et donc,
le moindre écartement
de la pureté
ou de la sainteté absolue,
c'est déjà péché.
Et en même temps,
les péchés,
il est quelque chose
d'actif.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
de tout simplement,
on va dire,
privation du bien,
mais c'est un mal actif.
Un mal,
si on veut dire,
positif.
Et dans ce sens-là,
c'est un mal moral positif.
Donc bien sûr,
ni tous les maux,
ni toute détresse
sont péchés,
mais tout péché
est une espèce
de manifestation
d'un mal moral
qui coupabilise.
Donc on a considéré
plusieurs aspects du péché,
plusieurs noms bibliques
pour définir le péché,
mais les conceptions,
je dirais,
les plus importantes
à garder,
c'est que le péché
est une transgression
à la loi des dieux
qui Dieu a verbalisé
à l'externe,
mais le péché
est avant tout
et surtout
l'impiété.
Donc même pour ceux,
Romain 5,
qui n'ont pas péché
selon la transgression
d'Adam
qui avaient reçu
une loi verbalisée
envers lui,
on a tous
expérimenté
la mort.
Et Romains,
chapitres 1 à 3,
vont nous prouver
que nous sommes
coupables
du péché
même si on n'a pas
reçu une loi
similaire à celle
d'Adam
ni une loi similaire
à celle
d'Israël
lorsque Moïse
a reçu la loi.
Donc,
pourquoi tous
ont traversé la mort ?
Car tous ont péché
et quelle est l'explication
de l'apôtre Paul ?
L'explication,
c'est
ayant la connaissance
des dieux,
car les attributs
invisibles des dieux
sont manifestes
à tous,
ils n'ont pas reconnu
Dieu pour Dieu,
ils ne l'ont pas rendu
grâce,
ils sont tous
donc inexcusables,
tous sont condamnés
à cause de leur
rébellion
contre Dieu
même qu'
par la révélation
naturelle,
même sans la Bible.
Personne ne va
à l'enfer
car ils n'ont pas
connu l'évangile,
ils vont à l'enfer
car ils se sont tous
rébellés contre Dieu
et ils sont doublement
condamnés bien sûr
si en ayant accès
à l'évangile,
ils refusent.
mais la Bible est claire
pour dire que nous sommes
tous condamnés,
tous inexcusables
car on a tous accès
à la révélation
générale des dieux.
Donc là,
on va de manière
très claire,
les péchés
sont quelque chose
qui est universel
et qui peut nous
coupabiliser tous
de manière effective,
mais nous sommes
dans cette condition
pas qu'à cause
du péché
qu'on pratique,
mais on est dans
cette condition
des condamnations
et même de cette pollution
qui nous contamine
à tous
à cause de la conception
du péché originel.
Et donc à partir
du paragraphe 2,
on a l'introduction
de cette conception.
Par ce péché,
nos premiers parents
ont perdu leur justice
originelle
et leur communion
avec Dieu.
Et nous,
en eux,
et c'est fait,
la mort est venue
sur tous,
tous sont devenus
morts dans le péché
et entièrement suyés
dans toutes les facultés
et les parties
de leur âme
et de leur corps.
Donc là,
nous sommes devant
l'introduction
de ce qu'on appelle
les péchés originels
et pour rappel,
il y a deux théories
pour essayer
de discerner
de quelle manière
l'universalité
du péché
est arrivée à nous.
Pourquoi nous sommes nés
dans cette corruption ?
Pourquoi les pages
de l'histoire
sont marquées
par les péchés ?
Pourquoi malgré
les aspirations
des noblesses
de l'homme
et les manifestations
de la grâce commune,
même si on peut
reconnaître
que l'homme
garde encore
les manifestations
partielles
de l'image
de Dieu,
de sa noblesse,
les pages
de l'histoire
et les vies
individuelles
de tous les êtres
humains
sont marquées
par les péchés ?
Donc,
pourquoi cette
universalité du péché ?
Et donc,
deux explications
dans la théologie
pour essayer
de considérer
de quelle manière
les péchés
originels d'Adam,
les premiers péchés
commis par l'humanité
nous touchent ?
Il y a cette notion
réaliste,
pour résumer,
c'est-à-dire
comme ils étaient
effectivement
les représentants
effectifs
de toute l'humanité,
c'est-à-dire
comme ils étaient
les premiers couples
duquel viendrait
toute l'humanité,
toute l'humanité
était effectivement
matériellement
quelque part
en eux.
Et comme
ils ont péché,
cette corruption
les a touchés
et donc
tous ceux
qui vont être
nés après eux
seront nécessairement
contaminés par les péchés
et coupables
du péché.
Par contre,
la manière
dont la Bible
montre
de façon encore
plus explicite
notre connexion
au péché
original d'Adam
n'est pas
tout simplement
par transmission
biologique
ou naturelle.
C'est
car nous sommes
coupabilisés
selon la parole
des dieux
du premier péché
d'Adam.
Si c'était
par transmission,
on serait coupabilisés
de tous les péchés
d'Adam
et de tous les péchés
commis par tous
nos ascendants.
Tous
de ceux
dont on a descendu.
Et donc,
la Bible,
elle n'est fait
que la connexion
avec ces premiers
péchés
d'Adam
pour parler
de notre
coupabilité,
condamnation.
Romain 5,
comme on a vu.
Et donc,
c'est clair
qu'il y a un aspect
de cette théorie
réaliste
qui nous parle
car effectivement,
la Bible a des passages
qui nous montrent
que, par exemple,
Abraham,
Lévi
a payé
la dîme
en Abraham
car il était
dans les
rangs d'Abraham
et,
en même temps,
il y a des difficultés
qu'on a déjà considérées.
Donc,
à partir de là,
on n'a pas besoin
d'abandonner
complètement
les nuances
du réalisme
qui sont là,
mais elles sont même
déclarées dans la confession
comme la manière
dont la corruption
est transmise.
Donc,
les conséquences
du péché
sont transmises
aussi
par descendance.
Par contre,
la question
de la coupabilité,
elle nous est plutôt
amputée
par la première
transgression
d'Adam.
Il était
les premiers
représentants
choisis pour Dieu
pour toute l'humanité
et en tant
que notre représentant
fédéral,
la deuxième théorie,
le fédéralisme,
car il nous représentait
toute l'humanité
et car il a échoué,
on est tous
devenus coupables
et voilà pourquoi
nous sommes tous
sous la condamnation
et sous la pollution
du péché
à cause du péché
d'Adam,
notre représentant légal.
Ce sont des choses
qu'on a vues
avec plus de temps,
je dois avancer.
Quand on considère
les péchés originels,
pour comprendre
on les divise
en deux aspects principaux.
Il y a
la culpabilité
originale
et il y a
la pollution
originelle.
pardon,
la culpabilité
originelle
et la pollution
originelle.
Et donc,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
à propos de cette
culpabilité
originelle ?
Donc,
l'exemple
que je vous ai donné
à la conclusion
de la dernière leçon,
c'est cette conception
d'amputation
que nous trouvons
dans la Bible
et que nous trouvons
aussi dans les milieux
judiciaires.
Je vous ai donné
l'exemple
en évangélisant
une petite fille
pour expliquer
l'évangile.
Je lui ai dit
qu'est-ce que ça
se passe avec toi
si jamais
tu ne te portes
pas très bien
pendant les classes ?
Je suis privé
de la récréer
et je dois
m'asseoir
dans un coin.
Et j'ai dit
en fait,
ce que Jésus fait,
c'est comme si
un élève
qui était très sage
lève les bras
et dit à la maîtresse,
maîtresse,
je sais qu'elle n'a pas
bien agi
mais moi,
comme j'étais
complètement obéissant,
je peux me mettre
à sa place
et donc
elle pourra
être libérée.
Donc,
je prends sa punition,
elle prend mes mérites,
elle part à la récré.
Et c'est intéressant
car il y a du temps
qui est passé,
cette partie
je n'ai pas raconté,
quand on est arrivé
proche de Noël,
elle est venue
d'elle-même
pour me dire
David,
j'ai l'impression
que Jésus,
il est mieux
que les Pères Noël
et je lui ai dit
tu as raison
mais pourquoi ?
Et elle m'a dit
car j'entends
parler tous les temps
que les Pères Noël,
ils n'offrent
des cadeaux
qu'à ceux
qui sont sages,
qui obéissent
tous les temps.
Mais là,
c'est dans ce que
tu m'as expliqué,
Jésus,
il offre son cadeau
même pour ceux
qui ne sont pas obéissants.
Et là,
j'ai dit,
tu as saisi,
tu as compris la grâce.
C'est véritablement ça
le cœur de l'évangile.
Et donc,
l'amputation,
c'est lorsque
un représentant officiel,
un représentant légal
se présente
devant les tribunaux
et nous les choisissons
comme notre représentant légal
devant Dieu.
Donc,
c'est Dieu
qui nous offre Christ,
qui lui a qualifié
en tant que
notre représentant légal.
Mais pour être
notre représentant légal
de manière effective,
non seulement
il doit
accomplir parfaitement
les exigences
des dieux
qu'on devrait accomplir,
mais il doit aussi
subir aux punitions
qui nous,
on mérite de souffrir.
Et les bases
de cette alliance
ne peuvent
qu'avoir lieu
car les bases
de cette alliance
ont été présentes
dès l'origine
de la création
de l'homme.
Lorsqu'il y a
Dieu rentre dans cette alliance
avec Adam,
nous,
on est plus concentré
dans sa chute,
mais même
la réussite,
s'il n'avait pas
échoué,
ça allait nous concerner.
Une meilleure position
devant Dieu
rendue éternelle
en mangeant
les fruits
de l'arbre de la vie.
On sait très bien
que cette chute
sous la permission
des dieux
envisageait déjà
qu'on mange
de vrais fruits
les Christs,
les fruits de la vie.
Mais pour l'instant,
quand on pense
à l'amputation
de la coupabilité
d'Adam
à toute l'humanité,
c'est car
il était
un vrai représentant légal.
Un autre exemple
biblique,
c'était l'exemple
de David
et Goliath.
Donc David,
c'était un arrangement
entre ces deux nations
où
ils vont,
au lieu de faire
la guerre
par leur armée
afin de préserver
tous les dégâts,
chacun choisit
un représentant
de chaque nation.
Et après cette dispute,
on va de manière très claire
que David seul
va assurer
la victoire
pour toute la nation.
Et donc c'était
un type du Christ déjà
et une didatique
envers la notion
d'amputation,
les mérites
d'une personne
appliquée
à tout ce
qu'il représente.
OK ?
Donc la coupabilité
d'Adam
est cette coupabilité
qui rend Dieu
juste
pour l'application
de toute cette punition
qui était promise.
Donc,
si tu mangeais
ces fruits,
certainement,
tu vas mourir.
Et là,
on apprend
et on se rappelle
et ça,
c'est très important
à nouveau,
pour plus naturel
que cette obéissance
était obligée
de la part
d'Adam et Ève,
il devrait
de toute manière
obéir.
On voit de manière
très claire
qu'il y a
une débat,
il y a
un changement,
une punition
qui a lieu
immédiatement
au moment
où il mange du fruit,
avant même
que Dieu déclare
la punition
de manière officielle
ou judiciaire.
Il perçoit
qu'ils sont nus,
ils ont la honte,
ils essayent
de fuir
la présence
de Dieu.
Donc,
ça,
c'est démontré
de manière
tout simplement
naturelle
comme toute
l'humanité
serait déjà
sous l'impact
de cette rébellion.
Par contre,
l'arrangement
d'alliance,
les cas d'alliance,
c'est pour rendre
cette formalisation
importante,
surtout pour notre
conception
aussi de l'évangile.
car la transgression,
elle devient
de plus en plus
importante
car elle était
volontaire
et explicitement
contraire
à la volonté
des dieux
qui les exhortait
pour les protéger
dès la chute
et pour les motiver
envers l'obéissance.
Et donc,
la transgression
de cette alliance
représente aussi
les bases
qui nous ont été posées.
Et donc,
cette coupabilité
est cette coupabilité
d'une rébellion
contre Dieu
qui était
une rébellion
radicale.
Même car,
lorsque nous considérons
toutes nos rébellions
contre Dieu
pour plus qu'on soit
responsable
pour chaque rébellion
ponctuelle
et culpable
de chaque rébellion
ponctuelle
qu'on fait
de nous-mêmes,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que la condition
privilégiée
d'Adam
représente,
je veux
que ça soit clair,
même si
sa corruption
était la moindre
possible,
si son péché
était petit,
il mériterait
déjà
la condamnation
éternelle
pour nous tous.
Car,
à nouveau,
je vous rappelle
comment on mesure
les péchés,
ce n'est pas par rapport
à la taille
du péché en soi,
mais contre qui
les péchés
sont commis.
Les péchés
sont toujours commis
contre la personne
la plus digne
de tout l'univers,
celle qui mérite
la plus grande
obéissance,
c'est lui
qui nous aime
le plus.
C'est un péché
commis contre
non seulement
la loi
impassible
de Dieu,
mais contre
Dieu lui-même
qui est l'être
totalement aimable,
le plus digne
de notre obéissance.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
la mode rébellion,
elle est déjà
digne d'une coupabilité
infinie.
Par contre,
c'était
une rébellion
commise
contre les plus
grandes manifestations
des générosités
des dieux
envers un être humain.
Aucun être humain
n'a jamais réjoui
d'une telle intimité
avec Dieu,
de cette richesse
que Dieu avait
pourvue
à l'humanité
à l'origine
et de cet état
original parfait.
Donc,
c'est clair
qu'étant
dans les sommets
des privilèges
d'intimité divine,
la rébellion
contre Dieu
devient la plus
coupable
qui est possible.
Et voilà pourquoi
nous participons
de cette coupabilité
qui est absolue.
Et donc,
c'est une coupabilité
qui produit
la mort,
mais la coupabilité
je vous rappelle
en soi-même
et de soi-même
est déjà empêchée
car on n'a pas été créé
pour être coupable,
pour être éloigné
des dieux aussi
par la coupabilité.
Et donc,
cette culpabilité
signifie
que par amputation
nous sommes morts
non pas
par nos péchés
tout simplement
qu'on commet
tous les jours,
mais par l'amputation
de la coupabilité
d'Adam.
Et le plus
on s'habitue
et le plus
on accepte
on assimile
et le plus
on embrasse
cette réalité,
le plus
on partira
envers la réconciliation
avec plus
des hâtes.
Si on ne voit pas,
c'est ça,
c'est quand on a posé
cette question
à CISPRO,
si Dieu n'était pas
très sévère
de la punition
qu'il avait apportée
à l'humanité
à cause du péché
d'Adam.
Il a dit
mais quoi ?
Cette poussière
tirée de la boue
il y a quelques jours
va se rébeller
contre Dieu
de cette manière
par insurrection,
insoumission.
Et donc là,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que quand on considère
combien coupables
nous sommes
en Adam,
c'est l'arrière-plan,
l'arrière-plan
le plus important
pour nous
à saisir
et à assimiler
et pour arrêter
d'essayer
de nous cacher
de notre coupabilité,
de chercher
à jouer
avec les subterfuges
qu'on voit aujourd'hui
par la psychanalyse,
cette attitude
de victimisation,
de toujours trouver
des excuses
et même lorsqu'on va
confesser
en même temps
qu'on est en train
d'assimiler nos fautes,
on est en train
de rajouter des excuses,
pour diminuer nos fautes,
on est totalement coupable,
on est pleinement coupable,
on est si coupable
qu'Adam
lorsqu'il a vécu
dans ce scénario parfait
et qu'il n'a pas
honoré Dieu
par son obéissance.
Et en ayant
embrassé la coupabilité,
en ayant confessé
notre coupabilité
en tant
qu'une race humaine,
à partir de là,
c'est plus facile aussi
d'assimiler
nos coupabilités
effectives.
Et donc,
ça c'est la notion
des coupabilités
amputées
ou la coupabilité
originelle,
ok ?
Et on se rappelle
très bien
que les péchés,
quand on parle
des péchés originels,
c'est cette solidarité
avec les péchés
d'Adam,
mais c'est aussi
de dire qu'à l'origine
des lettres,
au siège des lettres,
les péchés résident
et donc ils touchent
toutes nos facultés
et depuis la naissance,
nous sommes,
depuis l'origine,
nous sommes corrompus.
Et donc,
le deuxième aspect,
c'est l'aspect
de la corruption
ou pollution
originelle.
Et donc,
si la culpabilité
originelle
a à voir
avec cette
amputation
de la culpabilité
d'Adam
à nous tous,
et les contrastes
avec l'amputation
de cette culpabilité,
c'est la justification
légale,
donc quand Christ
nous couvre
avec sa droiture,
ses mérites,
Dieu nous déclare
juste car
il est en train
de nous amputer
à nous
la droiture
parfaite du Christ
et la dette
qu'il a payée
à la croix
par sa mort.
Et donc,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la justification.
Dieu qui nous déclare
juste car
la droiture
du Christ
nous a été amputée.
J'ai dans l'illustration
toujours
la barre
des vies
quand on joue
les jeux vidéo
des luttes,
il y a une barre
des vies.
OK ?
Et le plus
on est sous l'impact,
le plus la barre
des vies descend.
La vie du chrétien
qui est véritablement
unie à Christ
par la foi,
c'est une barre
des vies
qui ne va plus
jamais diminuer.
On est d'une fois
pour toutes
pour toujours
acceptable
pleinement vers Dieu
car la justice
du Christ
nous a été créditée.
Par contre,
la barre effective
de notre sanctification,
elle va progresser
doucement
et des fois
elle va
se rétrécir un peu.
dans les longs termes
ça sera toujours
un progrès
mais ça peut être
par un chiement
oscillant.
Donc,
Dieu
nous déclare
juste
par la doigte
parfaite du Christ
et Dieu
nous rend juste
par cette coopération
entre l'œuvre
de Saint-Esprit
et notre responsabilité
avec nos efforts
pour nous sanctifier.
C'est clair ?
Et donc là,
la pollution originelle
elle va faire
ses dialogues
quelque part
avec cette notion
pour les régénérés,
pour les chrétiens,
des régénérations
et des sanctifications
progressives.
Donc,
nous avons une justice
imputée
mais pour tous ceux
qui ont embrassé
Christ par la foi,
Dieu les a transformés,
Dieu les a régénérés
régénérés
et donc Dieu a infusé
en nous
une nouvelle vie.
Nous sommes greffés
à Christ
et en étant greffés
à Christ,
la vie du Christ,
cette union vitale
du Christ
va produire en nous
la justice.
Donc,
tout ce qui Dieu
déclare juste,
il rend juste.
OK ?
La déclaration
est absolue
tout comme la culpabilité
était absolue
en Adam
et la déclaration
des absolutions
est aussi absolue.
Et ensuite,
c'est intéressant
car la pollution
originelle,
elle était
une conséquence
radicale
de cette coupabilité
radicale.
Et donc,
la pollution
originelle,
c'est-à-dire
cette pollution
qu'Adam a expérimenté
tout de suite
après la chute,
c'est la même pollution
qui nous touche
depuis notre origine.
Et c'est là
où on voit
cet aspect
de transmission
même
dans la nature humaine.
Et donc,
nous sommes nés
corrompus
dès la naissance
et c'est-à-dire
que cette pollution
est une pollution
effective.
C'est la pollution
qu'on a héritée
d'Adam,
cette corruption.
Et quand on pense
à la pollution
originelle,
il y a deux
emphases principales
bibliques
que nous trouvons
dans les doctrines.
C'est l'emphase
de la dépravation
totale
et c'est l'emphase
aussi
de l'incapacité
totale.
Et donc,
quand on pense
à cette notion
de dépravation
totale,
on a plein de ces
qui nous donnent
l'idée
de l'incapacité
et donc,
donc,
David,
dans ses psaumes,
il parle
d'être né
dans l'iniquité.
En psaume 51,
c'est cette,
voici,
je suis né
dans l'iniquité.
Jérémie 17,
le cœur est tortueux
par-dessus tout
et il est méchant,
qui peut le connaître ?
Romain 8,
7,
car l'affection
de la chair
est l'inimitié
contre Dieu
parce qu'elle
ne se soumet pas
à la loi de Dieu
et qu'elle ne le peut
même pas.
Éphésiens 4,
17 et 18,
voici donc
ce que j'ai dit,
ce que je déclare
dans le Seigneur,
vous ne devez plus marcher
comme les païens
qui marchent
selon la vanité
de leurs pensées.
Ils ont l'intelligence
obscurcie
et ils sont étrangers
à la vie des dieux
à cause de l'ignorance
qui est en eux,
à cause de l'endourcissement
de leur cœur.
Car nous aussi,
nous étions autrefois
insensés,
site 3,
3,
désobéissants,
égarés,
asservis à toutes sortes
de convoitises
et des plaisirs
vivant dans la méchanceté
et dans la vie,
et dans l'envie,
dignes d'être haïs
en nous haïssant
les uns les autres.
On peut citer
Éphésiens 2
et même Romain,
mais ça va rentrer
encore plus
dans la notion
d'incapacité totale.
Mais c'est juste
quelle est l'explication
biblique
de cette dépravation
totale,
c'est que
comme les péchés
à son siège
à la source
de l'être,
tous les affluents
de cette rivière,
de cette source,
seront touchés
par les péchés.
Cela ne veut pas dire
que nous soyons
si dépravés
qu'on puisse l'être,
même si on a tous
les potentiels
d'être encore pire
qu'Hitler.
Dans la pratique,
la majorité d'entre nous
n'est pas
dans ces niveaux-là,
même avant la conversion.
Donc ce n'est pas
une question
d'être totalement
dépravés
dans les plans
potentiels
de notre dépravation,
mais c'est
d'être dépravés
ou corrompus
dans toutes les facultés
de l'être humain.
La corruption,
notamment,
avant tout,
morale,
mais aussi
les implications
par rapport au corps.
Je vous ai déjà
donné cet exemple,
en perdant la communion
avec Dieu,
en ayant l'esprit mort,
la description biblique,
l'esprit à mort,
on a perdu cet élément
de notre portion immatérielle
qui était celui
responsable
pour harmoniser les touts.
Donc si on pense
à un trépied
comme un banc
des trépieds,
là,
c'est comme si
l'esprit étant élevé,
on s'éplie parfois
par les directions
corrompues
de la chair physique
ou les directions
corrompues
de la chair morale.
Les péchés
de l'orgueil,
par exemple,
les péchés d'envie,
les péchés
de l'amour
à l'argent
ou l'amour
à la gloire
ou,
de l'autre côté,
les péchés
charnels.
Et donc,
la chair
corporelle
ayant un impact
sur les émotions,
les pensées,
les affections
et vice-versa.
Donc on va être
très clair
comment lorsqu'on est
fatigué,
la privation de sommeil,
etc.,
ça a un impact
aussi
envers
nos comportements,
la maîtrise
de soi,
nos humeurs,
etc.
Et donc on est
clairement
dans une condition
où nous ne sommes
plus gouvernés
par l'esprit
car l'esprit
il est mort.
Et là on est en train
de parler notamment
de notre condition
surtout avant la chute.
Et donc,
nous ne sommes pas
si dépravés
qu'on puisse l'être.
Ce n'est pas non plus
une privation totale
d'un sens signé
envers Dieu.
Donc l'apôtre Paul,
il va décrire
ces personnes
qui sont étrangères
à la vie des dieux
comme en étant
intentionnellement.
L'athéisme n'existait pas
pour des vrais.
L'athéisme
est une réaction
envers les évidences
des dieux
qui nous condamnent
tous les temps.
C'est une suppression
et le langage biblique
c'est ayant la connaissance
des dieux.
Dieu révèle
sa colère déceux
contre
l'injustice
des hommes
et l'impiété
qui ont supprimé
la vérité,
qui ont rendu
la vérité captif.
Et donc là
c'est très clair
selon la Bible
que ces sens
inés des dieux
tous les êtres humains
les ont encore.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que l'homme soit
avec sa conscience
totalement cautérisée.
La conscience
de l'être humain
elle est progressivement
cautérisée.
Les plus ils pêchent
et les plus graves
leurs péchés,
les plus ils s'habituent
avec leurs péchés.
Les plus dormants
ils sont envers
la répentance.
Mais en même temps
elle n'est pas,
elle n'est jamais
totalement cautérisée
pour que l'homme
soit complètement absent
de son sens
des coupabilités.
Ça ne veut pas dire
non plus
qu'il soit incapable
d'admirer les vertus
ou incapable
d'action
ou des sentiments
désintéressés.
Car même la libéralité
peut être pratiquée
par orgueil,
par les désirs
d'être vu
comme quelqu'un
dégénéreux,
par l'autre promotion
de soi-même.
Et donc là
c'est intéressant,
c'est pas que
tous les non-régénérés
seront toujours impliqués
dans toutes les formes
des péchés.
Et c'est clairement
le fait
que nous ayons tous
la capacité
et les potentiels
de commettre
tous les types de péchés.
Voilà pourquoi
c'est important
pour Christ
d'être tenté
en toute chose
toutefois sans péché.
Et voilà pourquoi
il peut être qualifié
comme notre substitut
car il a vaincu
toutes les tentations.
Et la réalité
c'est que
cela signifie
que l'homme
dans sa condition échouée
possède une corruption
inhérente
depuis la racine
de son être
qui touche
toutes ses facultés
de son âme
et de son corps.
Ça signifie
que l'homme
dans sa condition
non-régénérée
n'a aucun
bien spirituel
en lui-même.
Il a encore
des biens naturels,
il a encore
des vertus
car les restes
de l'image de Dieu
ne sont pas non plus
totalement supprimés.
Il y a ce concept
de la grâce commune,
on peut profiter
de plusieurs développements
de la pensée humaine,
de la culture,
de la médecine
mais il faut savoir
qu'ils sont tous
tachés par les péchés.
Ils sont fondamentalement
torts
dans toutes leurs disciplines,
surtout les disciplines
humaines,
non exactes
car les disciplines exactes
ce sont les lois
des dieux
qui prédominent,
la mathématique,
la physique, etc.
On n'a pas
comment échapper.
Par contre,
pour les discernements
du problème
de l'homme
et du comportement
et de comment régler
les problèmes
de l'homme,
c'est quelles
les écritures
qui peuvent pourvoir
des traitements
purs,
véritables,
efficaces
car même s'il y a
quelques mesures
de vérité
dans certains diagnostics,
les plus probables,
ces diagnostics
et ces traitements
seront tachés
par une inclinaison
à échapper
des dieux
et de ces traitements
frontaux.
Les essais
tout simplement
de supprimer
la coupabilité,
ce sont des efforts
classiques
dans la psychanalyse,
c'est déjà
complètement
à l'opposé
de l'objectif
biblique
qui nous pousse
à assimiler,
à assumer
la coupabilité
et traiter
nos problèmes
de manière frontale.
Et donc,
même si
on ne doit pas
refuser complètement
toutes sources
qui peuvent jouer
à contribuer
pour notre connaissance
dans plusieurs disciplines,
nous n'avons
qu'est la parole
de Dieu
qui nous donne
la capacité
de filtrer
cette connaissance
et qu'est la parole
de Dieu
qui peut nous donner
un diagnostic
précis
et les traitements
radicals
dont on a besoin.
Donc,
les problèmes
des lettres
ments,
surtout quand on considère
son problème radical,
les problèmes
du péché,
avec tous les
symptômes
de péché,
c'est important
pour nous
de nous rappeler
que nous,
en tant que chrétiens
et nous,
en tant qu'Église,
on sache
que Dieu
a conféré
et confié
exclusivement
à l'Église
la capacité
de donner
un diagnostic
radical
des problèmes
d'être humain.
Pour ceux
qui ne sont pas
encore sauvés
et qui ont
toute leur vie
busculée
avec plein de problèmes
dans plusieurs
ères différentes
de leur vie,
ils peuvent
chercher
avec une bonne
mesure
des palliatifs
pour alléger
la souffrance
dans plusieurs ères
ou même
pour débloquer
quelques traumas
de manière
très pragmatique.
J'ouvre en parenthèse
pour donner un exemple
mais si quelqu'un
arrive à me convaincre
que l'effet
que j'ai peur
de nager,
ce qui n'est pas vrai,
mais si j'avais peur
de nager
et que quelqu'un
découvre dans mon passé
un épisode
où c'était
à cause du fait
que mon tonton
a joué avec moi
dans la piscine
et qui m'a gardé
plus longtemps,
cette personne
peut me convaincre
peut-être
que c'est là
en fait
où tout a été déclenché.
Elle peut même
me convaincre
à me débarrasser
de cette peur
et de revenir
à la plage
pour nager.
Mais le fait
que pragmatiquement
j'ai réglé
un problème
dans ma vie,
un trauma,
il n'y a aucune
assurance
que ce soit vrai,
que ce soit
véritablement
la raison
pour laquelle
j'avais un trauma
pour nager.
Vous comprenez ?
Inexact.
On est en train
de jouer
avec le pragmatisme
mais pas forcément
avec la vérité.
Le problème,
c'est que
quelque part,
tous nos peurs
trouvent
une racine radicale
dans mon
inimitié
avec Dieu.
et c'est un problème
tellement radical
qu'une fois
réglé
à la source,
je peux
traiter
tous les autres
problèmes de ma vie
progressivement
à partir de là.
Cela ne veut pas dire
que tous les petits
traumas de la vie
peuvent être réglés
par là,
mais c'est pour dire
que Dieu
nous a donné
la commission
de traiter
les problèmes
de l'humanité
dès la racine.
Les problèmes
de l'humanité,
c'est la dépravation
totale à cause
d'une rébellion
contre Dieu.
Et l'Église
doit rester
dans son poste.
Et l'Église
doit chercher
à traiter
les problèmes.
Lloyd-Jones,
il va dire par exemple
que ça serait
crimineux
de la part
d'un médecin
si
quelqu'un
qui a un cancer
des poumons
arrive
et les symptômes
c'est là tous.
Et les médecins,
il a la capacité
d'appliquer
quelques médicaments
qui vont enlever
la douleur.
Ils vont
enlever
les symptômes.
Et ça,
c'est crimineux.
Car les symptômes
sont toujours
en train de pointer
envers un problème
plus grave.
Quand on pense
tout de suite
aux psychotropes
devant un problème,
on doit se demander
qu'on est en train
de dribler la conscience,
les crises,
on est en train
de cacher
les vrais problèmes.
Et la réalité,
c'est qu'à la fin
des comptes,
la racine
radicale
de tous nos problèmes,
c'est
inimitié contre Dieu,
coupabilité,
enfer.
Et c'est la réconciliation
avec Dieu
qui peut traiter
la déprivation
totale
de l'homme.
Tous nos pouvoirs
sont mal utilisés
et la Bible
va décrire
cette déprivation
totale
par des termes
comme la chair
avec ses désirs
et ses passions,
concupissance,
les vieilles hommes,
la loi
d'un homme membre
qui nous pousse
envers les péchés,
ses corps des péchés,
ses corps mortels,
les pensées
charnelles.
C'est vraiment
une condition.
C'est d'être
dans une condition
radicale
des pollutions.
Nous ne sommes pas
pécheurs
car on pêche.
nous péchons
car nous sommes
dans une condition
de déprivation
totale.
Et donc,
il n'y a pas
de guérison
par des traitements
palliatifs.
La guérison
n'a qu'un médicament
laissé en Jésus-Christ.
Donc,
c'est important
d'avoir cette notion
pour l'autoconnaissance
mais aussi
pour comprendre
l'Évangile,
pour expérimenter
l'Évangile
et pour prêcher
l'Évangile.
Donc,
la chair
elle a
toute cette explication
biblique.
C'est un principe
qui s'incline
en opposition
au Saint-Esprit
à l'étrangement
de la vie divine.
L'exemple
que Dieu donne
à Nicodème,
c'est que
ceux qui sont nés
de la chair
sont chers
ou ceux qui sont
nés de l'Esprit.
La race humaine,
elle est décrite
comme une race
dépravée.
c'est la race
qui est évoluée
ou qui a progressé
quelque part
sans l'habitation
de l'Esprit
du vent
à partir du moment
où Adam
a péché.
Donc,
c'est une vie
qui est marquée
par les manques
d'intégrité,
d'équilibre.
C'est une vie
de luxure
de la chair
ou du corps
excentrique
de l'orgueil
intellectuel,
de l'égocentrisme,
l'usage des facultés
pour des fins idolâtres
au lieu
de l'utiliser
pour la gloire
des dieux.
Et donc,
la démonstration ultime
se trouve
en Ephésiens
chapitre 2.
Je pense que
c'est important
qu'on lise
les passages
verset 1 à 8.
Voilà la condition
de l'être humain
avant la conversion.
Vous étiez mort
par vos offenses
et par vos péchés.
Voilà pourquoi
ces stratégies
d'utiliser la musique
pour créer
une orientation
émotionnelle
et faire l'appel
à l'autel
et faire les personnes
répéter des prières,
ça n'a aucun effet
réel
si quelque chose
ne se passe pas
par l'œuvre
des régénérations
du Saint-Esprit.
On ne peut pas
se tromper
comme si on pourrait
convertir les personnes,
faire la vision
des équiles,
cette vallée
des ossements
desséchés
qui n'ont,
on n'a aucune capacité
de ressusciter
les êtres humains
spirituellement parlant.
C'est qui Dieu
qui peut les faire ?
À nous de proclamer
la parole
avec fidélité,
à Dieu de faire
le travail
de la régénération.
Et donc là,
il dit,
vous étiez morts
par vos offenses
et par vos pensées,
par vos péchés,
pardon,
dans lesquels
vous marchiez autrefois.
Selon les trains
de ces mondes,
donc voilà,
on est dominé,
on n'arrive pas
à résister
à l'influence
de la collectivité
corrompue.
Les mondes,
dans sa corruption,
n'est rien de plus
que la collectivité
des individus
corrompus.
ce n'est pas
les milieux
qui corrompent
l'homme,
sinon les milieux
ne seraient jamais
corrompus.
Qui a corrompu
les milieux ?
Les individus
corrompus.
Et donc la réalité,
ce qu'on voit
dans la Bible,
la description,
c'est nous marchions
autrefois
selon les trains
de ces mondes.
Et qu'est-ce
qui caractérise
les trains de ces mondes ?
Selon les princes
et la puissance
de l'air,
c'est Satan.
L'esprit
qui agit maintenant
dans les fils
de la rébellion.
Voilà pourquoi
pour plus qu'on veuille
profiter
de la grâce commune
et se donner
le droit même
de regarder
certaines séries
ou films,
il faut savoir
dès le départ
que nous devons
nous protéger
constamment
des gouttes
de vénin
qui seront là.
Car c'est corrompu.
Et donc,
il faut faire
un travail
très très puissant
pour résister.
Dans la plupart
des cas,
on n'arrive jamais
à passer
les troisième
ou quatrième épisode
d'aujourd'hui
de la plupart
de séries.
même un épisode
des fois,
c'est déjà
impossible.
Et donc,
c'est important
pour nous
d'être critérieux
et de savoir
que nos lectures,
c'est la même chose.
Cette tentation
d'être très cultivée
selon les mondes,
je me rappelle très bien,
avant même
ma conversion,
la lecture
des certains classiques,
pour moi,
c'était très
polluant.
Ce sont des êtres humains
qui savent
et qui apprennent
très facilement
à attirer
notre attention
et garder
par les tentations.
Déjà,
Augustin,
dans son époque,
il disait
« faites attention
aux pièces de théâtre »
car plusieurs
chrétiens
qui n'auraient
jamais les courage
de pratiquer
un acte
d'adultère
à l'extérieur
sont en train
de satisfaire
cette demande pécheresse
par la contemplation
des pièces de théâtre.
L'esprit
qui agit maintenant
dans les fils
de la rébellion.
Nous tous aussi,
nous étions
de leur nombre
et nous vivions autrefois
selon les convoitises
de notre chair,
sclaves,
accomplissant les volontés
de la chair,
de nos pensées
et nous étions
par nature
des enfants
des colères,
par nature
comme les autres.
Voilà pourquoi
quand on pense
au calvinisme
ou à la conception biblique
et même les premiers siècles
quand on pense
vraiment à cette conception
pourquoi Dieu doit être
souverain dans les saluts.
C'est car c'est impossible
à n'importe quel être humain
de décider pour Dieu,
de changer sa nature,
de se ressusciter lui-même
ou de nous
qui sommes chrétiens
de ressusciter les autres.
Et donc remarquez bien
quelle est notre participation
dans les passages.
Nous,
enfants des colères,
suivant les coursus
de ces mondes,
esclaves déconvatisés
de notre chair,
par nature
fils des colères.
Qui est le sujet,
qui est le responsable
dans ces passages
du changement ?
Alors,
Dieu a pu prêcher
un serment en entier
juste sur cette particule-là
pour passer ces mots.
Mais,
mais Dieu,
nous,
péché,
esclavage,
mort spirituelle.
Mais,
Dieu,
qui est riche
en miséricorde
à cause du grand amour
dont il nous a aimés.
C'est-à-dire,
ce n'était pas à cause
du fait qu'il a prévu
que j'allais choisir pour lui,
ce n'était pas à cause
de quelque chose
qu'il y avait en moi
qu'il a pu apprécier,
mais c'était à cause
du grand amour
dont il nous a aimés.
Dieu n'est pas en train
de regarder à l'extérieur
pour trouver des raisons
pour nous aimer,
il regarde au-dedans
de lui-même
sa capacité
d'aimer
inconditionnellement.
Nous qui étions morts
dans nos offenses,
il nous a rendu la vie.
Donc,
qui nous a rendu la vie ?
Dieu,
comment ?
Avec Christ.
C'est par la grâce
que vous êtes sauvés.
Régénération
qui précède
même la foi
et la répentance.
Il nous a ressuscités
ensemble
et il nous a fait
asseoir dans les lieux
célestes
en Jésus-Christ
afin de montrer
dans les siècles à venir
l'infinie richesse
de sa grâce
par sa bonté
envers nous
en Jésus-Christ.
Car c'est par la grâce
que vous êtes sauvés,
par les moyens de la foi
et cela ne vient pas
de vous,
c'est les dons de Dieu.
C'est impossible
d'être plus clair.
Et si ce n'est pas
à nouveau,
si ce ne sont pas
en sens des justices
corrompues
qui veulent refuser
la souveraineté
des Jeux
de leur salut,
qui veulent refuser
la conception biblique
de la dépravation totale,
si ce n'est pas
des vers remplis
qui ne veulent pas
laisser rentrer
la parole de Dieu,
on n'arrive pas
à expliquer
comment les personnes
arrivent à refuser
un passage
tellement clair
et tellement riche.
Donc là,
on est déjà
introduit
dans leur capacité totale.
Donc,
on a plein
de versets bibliques
qu'on ne peut pas toucher,
mais les Léopards,
est-ce qu'il a
la capacité
d'échanger
ses,
comme vous dites
en français,
ses tâches ?
Donc,
la description biblique,
elle est tellement claire
sur l'impossibilité.
il n'y a aucun
qui cherche Dieu.
Donc,
il y a des églises
qui essaient
de s'adapter
à ceux
qui sont en train
de chercher Dieu.
Mais la Bible
nous dit clairement,
il n'y a aucun
homme qui cherche
Dieu véritablement.
Nous l'aimons
car il nous a aimés
d'abord.
Si ce n'est pas
l'action des dieux
envers nous
pour précéder
notre action
envers lui,
c'est impossible
à n'importe quel être
car dans sa corruption
totale,
il y a cet aspect
qu'on appelle
la corruption
totale,
cet aspect
qu'on appelle
l'incapacité
totale.
Donc,
l'incapacité,
elle déclare
que l'homme
est totalement
incapable
de satisfaire Dieu
car toutes ses motivations,
affections
et actions
sont défectueuses.
Ces personnes
ne sont pas promptes
par un amour
pour Dieu
pour faire
les bonnes actions
qu'ils essayent
de faire.
et
l'apôtre époil
est très clair,
si
nous ne faisons
pas la moindre
chose
pour la gloire
des dieux,
nous faisons
la moindre chose
pour la mauvaise
motivation.
Est-ce qu'on est
en train de promouvoir
notre réputation
ou penser
au futur bien
qu'on est en train
de recevoir
si on sème les biens ?
Mais si nous ne sommes
pas motivés
par l'amour
des dieux
sur toute autre chose
et un amour
sincère
aux prochains
comme à moi-même,
on a tous
échoué
par rapport
aux motivations
des biens
qu'on doit faire.
Donc l'aspect
spirituel
de la loi
rend impossible
qu'il être
humain puisse faire
les moindres
actes
d'obéissance
en perfection.
En fait,
les meilleurs actes
qu'on n'a jamais faits,
il a plus servi
à notre condamnation
qu'à notre absolution.
Car tous nos actes
sont tachés,
même nos bonnes œuvres,
sont tachés
par les péchés.
car on n'est pas
en train de les faire
avec la plénitude
de la motivation
qu'on devrait avoir
pour la gloire des dieux.
Et donc,
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
que l'être humain
est incapable
d'aller dans la direction
des dieux
de manière
à l'adorer véritablement.
Il est incapable
de choisir pour Dieu.
de changer
sa condition,
sa corruption.
s'il n'est pas
né des dieux,
il ne peut pas
sortir de cette condition.
Il est totalement
capable
de sortir
de la condition,
de changer
sa prédisposition
et préférer
et préférences
fondamentales
pour les péchés.
Il n'est même
pas capable
des premiers abordages
pour ces changements.
Aucune compréhension
ou appréciation
même pour les vérités
spirituelles.
Comment Paul écrit
au Corinthien ?
Car les choses
spirituelles
se discernent
spirituellement.
Vous avez reçu
les pensées
des dieux.
Mais l'homme
naturel
ne peut pas
comprendre
les choses
des dieux.
Il ne peut même
pas comprendre
l'évangile
si en même temps
que l'évangile
est proclamé,
le Saint-Esprit
n'est pas en train
d'agir
pour produire
cet appel
intérieur.
Car même
les plus grandes
manifestations du Christ
à l'externe
n'ont pas été
suffisantes
pour sauver
les multitudes.
Couplé
au témoignage
externe
de la proclamation
de l'évangile,
le Saint-Esprit
doit agir
à l'intérieur.
L'apôtre Paul
a eu cette vision
du Christ
mais la manière
dont il décrit
sa conversion
c'est quand il a
plu à celui
qui m'a séparé
de l'évangile
de ma mère
de révéler
son fils
en moi,
au-dedans
de moi.
Et donc
l'incapacité
totale
elle parle
de cette condition.
Et les derniers
ont un aspect
qu'on a considéré
c'est l'aspect
des restes
du péché
chez les croyants.
Nous allons lire
les paragraphes
de la confession
pour résumer
un peu
cette conception
d'incapacité
totale
et d'épravation
et ensuite
on va passer
au paragraphe 5.
Paragraphe 3
puisqu'ils étaient
la souche
du Jean-Rouman
et par les vouloirs
des dieux
ils représentaient
toute l'humanité.
La culpabilité
du péché
a donc été
amputée
et la nature
corrompue
a été transmise
par eux
à toute leur
postérité
par les processus
normales
de la génération.
Donc
amputation
de la culpabilité
et transmission
de la pollution.
Leurs descendants
sont maintenant
conçus dans les péchés
et sont
par nature
des enfants de colère,
des serviteurs
de péché
assujettis
à la mort
et à toutes sortes
de misères spirituelles
temporelles
et éternelles
à moins
que les seigneurs
ne les libèrent.
Donc
totalement
incapables
si les seigneurs
ne les libèrent.
De cette
corruption originale
par laquelle
nous sommes
complètement infectés
incapables
et ennemis
des tout biens
et entièrement
portés
à toutes sortes
des mâles
proviennent
toutes les transgressions
actuelles.
Désespéremment
corrompues
est le cœur
de l'homme.
Et donc là
on conclut
la considération
de notre
condition
pécheresse
comme héritée
de la chute
originale
d'Adam
mais il y a
un dernier
paragraphe
qui traite
de la permanence
des restes
du péché
même chez les chrétiens.
Et là
je pense qu'on est
très bien équipé
avec notre série
d'études sur Galate
car toute la lettre
est en train
de faire des exhortations
à marcher
selon l'esprit.
Et donc
paragraphe 5
la corruption
de la nature
demeure
pendant cette vie
sur terre
en ceux
qui sont
régénérés.
Bien que les croyants
en aient reçu
les pardons
en Christ
et qu'elles
soient
mortifiées
cette corruption
ainsi que les actions
qui en procèdent
est vraiment
et au sens propre
péché.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut
dire par là ?
Pourquoi ?
Il faut que ça soit clair
car à partir du moment
où nous sommes
régénérés
il y a encore
deux batailles
possibles
sous les mauvaises influences
au sein de l'Église.
L'antinomisme
qui va confondre
ces deux choses
et qui va dire
comme la droiture
parfaite
m'a déjà été amputée
et ma barre
de justice
est complète
pour toujours
je peux vivre
n'importe comment.
C'est
les libertinages.
Et de l'autre côté
il y a
les légalismes
qui va dire
ok
bon
Christ nous a justifié
maintenant
il faut qu'on
préserve
cette sainteté
sinon on va perdre
les saluts.
Et par la base
de la performance
on essaye
de surmonter
la dépravation totale
sauf que cette attitude
envers la loi
va produire
plus de tentations
car on n'est pas
en train de puiser
les puissances
pour vaincre les péchés
au bon endroit.
On est en train
de puiser les puissances
pour vaincre les péchés
sur les menaces
de la loi
sur une idée
d'un Dieu contre nous
et pas sur
cette relation
paternelle des dieux
dont la relation
intime avec Christ
est la source
la plus efficace
des puissances
pour vaincre les péchés.
Et donc
nous devons appeler
péché
même après
la totale absolution.
Je nous dis
aux chrétiens
si nous disons
que nous n'avons pas péché
nous mentons
et nous faisons
Dieu menteur.
Mais il dit aussi
que les vrais
enfants de Dieu
ne peuvent pas
rester dans la pratique
du péché.
Qui est les chrétiens ?
C'est celui
qui a la possibilité
des plus péchés ?
Non.
Il est celui
qui ne reste pas
dans la pratique
du péché.
C'est quelqu'un
qui progresse
dans sa bataille
contre les péchés
et qui arrive
à mortifier.
Donc la condition
chez les chrétiens
Galate
c'est la description
je pense
la plus explicite
pour nous.
Donc
nous
avec la nouvelle nature
nous sommes morts
pour nous-mêmes
et nés pour Dieu.
Nous sommes morts
avec Christ
pour vivre pour Dieu.
Langage de Paul
en Galate.
Et à partir de là
l'apôtre Paul
il va dire
que comme
notre nouvelle nature
a une volonté
prédominante
c'est plaire Dieu.
Nous scientifier.
Gééé Pâquer
dans son livre
sur la dynamique
du Saint-Esprit
il dit
que
l'expression
sainteté
a le même
poids
électrisant
que les mots
sexe
pour
les non-chrétiens.
Si on est
dans une salle
avec plein de personnes
et quelqu'un
dit les mots sexe
on va tous arrêter
regarder la personne.
Alors ça
c'est quelque chose
qui révèle
le plus
la puissance
péché rationnelle.
Par contre
pour les vrais
chrétiens
en bonne santé
si quelqu'un
dit les mots
sainteté
tous les vrais
chrétiens
seront très intéressés
et vont se diriger
vers la conversation.
Ça devrait être
comme ça.
Et donc là
la volonté
prédominante
du chrétien
c'est une volonté
qui va
dans la même
direction
des commandements
des dieux
de la sainteté.
En même temps
Paul dit
que les
Saint-Esprit
habitent en nous.
Donc la troisième
personne de la Trinité
qui nous pointe
l'échément
de la sainteté
qui exerce
son influence
en nous.
Par contre
Paul va dire aussi
que même si la chair
a été crucifiée
avec Christ
donc elle a déjà
reçu un coup
mortel
elle fait
des appels
contre la volonté
du Saint-Esprit.
Donc les restes
du péché
chez les chrétiens
les plus importants
à saisir
c'est que lorsqu'on
pêche
on pêche vraiment
Christ est un avocat
qui reste là
en train d'intercéder
pour nous
mais c'est important
de renouveler
notre conviction
du pardon radical
obtenu la croix
mais c'est important
pour nous
de confesser
constamment
nos fautes
ok
et de progresser
en sainteté
mais c'est important
pour nous
de savoir
que nous ne pouvons
pas embrasser
une culture évangélique
ni qui va
dans la direction
des séquérités
connues
comme les piétismes
qui proposent
la perfection
dans cette vie
la possibilité
de ne plus jamais péché
mais de l'autre côté
on ne doit pas accepter
cette conception
charnelle
pour les chrétiens
qui va
donner
une force
au reste de péché
beaucoup plus grande
qu'est celle
qu'on voit
dans le Nouveau Testament
j'aurai bien sûr
pas le temps
de vous présenter
ma position
à propos de Roman 7
mais moi
je suis convaincu
qu'un roman
l'apôtre Paul
il cherche
à décrire
les nouveau-nés
comme quelqu'un
qui est prédominamment
victorieux
contre la chair
si nous sommes
en train d'employer
les moyens des grâces
avec diligence
si nous sommes
en train de nous nourrir
correctement
de tous les moyens
des grâces
pour nous sanctifier
si nous sommes
diligents vers la sanctification
nous serons
prédominamment
victorieux
contre les péchés
c'est impossible
qu'il reste de la chair
soit plus fort
qu'il est
le Saint-Esprit
qui habite en nous
et qu'il est notre
nouvelle nature en Christ
et c'est notamment
cette perspective
de la sainteté
qui conduit une église
à effectivement
réjouir
de l'opposé
de l'incapacité totale
et de l'opposé
de la dépravation totale
car nous sommes
régénérés
dès la source de l'être
le Saint-Esprit
vient habiter
dès la source de l'être
et Christ
est entronisé
au cœur
et c'est celui
qui prédomine
sur nos cœurs
nos pensées
nos émotions
les dieux de la paix
va garder nos pensées
en Jésus Christ
et c'est